[Musique]
je ne boude
mais qu'est ce que tu fais là je fais du
son la ces excellents on peut faire à
frites ça tu veux fit et ouais ok alors
avec moi ou un tuyau fuit fois
[Musique]
j'attends
normandie là je suis totalement jet la
guerre je déteste le café à part ce qui
retarde match 12
en fait c'est une collab givenchy
niedola j'ai la fibre chez moi ouais par
contre c'est chelou jusqu'à 4 min vice
et les inrocks
et si on faisait une petite balade
digestive mais en segway carrément bada
excusez moi vous avez des balistes au au
seigle en fait moi j constamment entre
elles et tokyo
c'est à dire pas à roubaix c'est ça tu
acheté toutes les vannes sur piles
sommes sortis j'ai pas trop faire des
figures en skate ouais je préfère cruz
et ouais
[Musique]
c'est bien
parfois des besoins me déconnecter un
peu moins 10 minutes quoi j'adore place
ont ils fait des [ __ ] twitter ouais
j'ai souscrit une assurance montirat
qu'à toi alors ouais je suis carrément
foulbé gagnent un bon à part quand la
date très très bonne viande
et si on choisit une expo street art
non désolé je suis pas dispo demain en
soirée dans ce mix chez moi tout seul
niles
je pense que je vais faire un seizième
tattoo au niveau de la pub
one way gt4 et photos avec mon appareil
jetable tora le résultat dans deux
semaines mais zing shatter comme ça
non
[Musique]
j'adore ça
c'est clairement
merci
[ __ ] mais c'est
m
[Musique]
je comprends ap attends mais tu as une
vie sociale
ouais si tu mets un pouce en l'air c'est
parce que c'est cool tu mon pouce en bas
c'est parce que c'est waou
c'était clairement excellence était
totalement fucked up j'ai une petite
question est ce qu'on n'a pas fait un
[ __ ] de tubes la crème mon mec c'était
juste insein incroyable à temps est ce
que finalement il n'est pas déjà dépassé
moi j'avoue j'ai muet ouais j'aime upp
j'aime plus simple mais nous sommes sûrs
c'est has been de haut
tu t'investis et
[Musique]
maintien